(audience applauding)
And welcome back!
I'm here with one of my heroes,
and Shark Tank star, Mark Cuban.
You're so much more than Shark Tank, you're just everything.
Including a future president, I hope.
Anyway, it's Pasta Week on our show.
Are you a pasta fan?
I love pasta, and it's one of the few things I can cook.
And I'm one of those guys, that's just like literally
throws the spaghetti up against the wooden cabinet
to see if it sticks.
That way I know it's done.
Al dente. It's perfect.
Well, there're a lot of pasta inventions out there,
gadgetry, ways in which to cook,
we have a little rack here that hangs the pasta
and a device that also cuts portions for like lasagna,
which is actually brilliant.
Because lasagna doesn't really have a lot of rules
in how you make it and how you present it.
And we have an inventor here who wants to showcase
his pasta product and get a few business tips from you,
if that's possible?
Of course!
All right, Greg Getzinger, will you please get out here?
(audience cheering and applauding)
You too.
Hi Greg, how are you? I'm so happy to meet you.
I'm happy to meet you.
Are you tripping out
that like Shark Tank music is playing,
we're here and this gentleman is here?
Yeah, it's unbelievable.
I know, I'm having a totally-
Pinch me, pinch me.
Totally surreal moment. Pinch me too, pinch me.
Okay. See?
Whatever.
It's not a dream.
All right.
Greg, since we have Mark's attention and the luxury of it,
tell us about your product.
My product is for lasagna,
is for portioning pans of lasagna into equal portions.
When I invented this product it's because I used to have
experience in the restaurant industry,
I owned my own pizza business
and portioning is very important.
This is very simple to use and very easy to do,
and it makes life a lot easier.
Is this design more for commercial or in-home?
I designed it for commercial.
Uh-huh.
But it is something that I want to bring
to the retail market, because it's so simple to use.
And even in the,
(audience and Mark applauding)
in our homes, home foodies who bake and cook,
you have to have simple to use tools.
Sure. Right.
So, will you show us how to do this?
Yeah, you just slide it on,
but you'll notice that it'll snap in place
so it doesn't move around.
Oh, there we go.
It snaps?
Got it.
Yeah.
So there it's nice in place.
Now all you have to do is grab your spatula-
Look at Drew over there, it's like.
(Mark makes squealing noises)
Horrible, hey? You get me, Mark.
See, and you don't have to use a knife,
you can use a spatula, because you're gonna have to use
the spatula to-
Pull it out anyway?
Anyways, right?
So just-
And you just cut though, up.
Also, I'm messy.
Oh, you can feel it going all the way to the bottom
of the pan, so you know it's done.
Exactly.
See, it's very simple to cut, right?
(Greg and audience laugh)
And you could also play Tic-Tac-Toe. No, not quite.
Yeah. Well, they're also for the bigger portions.
I have a lasagna Portion PadL that's also made
to do nine portions, it's two of 'em.
Okay, so we just?
So you just pull it up, lift it up.
They're all cut into equal portions.
Oh, and it's not even really dirty either, so.
No.
Yeah.
'Cause I know I'm not gonna clean it anyways.
(Greg laughs)
Now these are bigger portions,
and that's where the nine portion lasagna Portion PadL
comes into play.
That's a big old portion.
Nice.
Yes it is.
(audience applauding)
But my wife, when she makes her lasagna,
we either use the bigger portion or smaller portion,
depending on how many people are sitting at the table.
Mark, thoughts?
I think it's cool, right?
Thanks.
I mean, commercial I can definitely see it, right?
Because you wanna portion control and you want consistency,
right, so that's why you did it?
At home, you know, I grew up three boys,
so we would have been fighting,
so this would have been great,
'cause we already got the same size pizza.
So then the question is, how much does it cost to buy,
and where can I buy it?
Well, it's on my website-
Which is?
www.PortionPadL.com, you can spell it wither way,
P A D D L E or P A D L, which is my-
Okay, PortionPadL.com., right?
.Com. Yes.
And how much does it cost?
The commercial cost is 134.95.
Consumer, I'm gonna run a special for anybody out there,
it'll be for 82.95.
So it's not cheap, but it's effective, right?
Right, it is not cheap, but the lasagna Portion PadL,
it could be scaled to a lower price with-
Right.
Will buy 'em.
Well, we polled our audience actually
to see how likely they would be to purchase
this PadL, and 81% of our audience said
that they would buy it.
Dang Greg, that was like insane. Well done.
(audience cheering and applauding)
It's nice to be able to test the water and the temperature
and see that there is interest there.
Yeah, for sure.
Mark, would you be so kind,
as to maybe give Greg some advise at sone point?
Yeah, of course. Yeah, I'm happy to help.
And give him your honest opinion behind the scenes?
Yeah, I'll get you all my information off screen,
and yeah-
That'd be wonderful.
Yeah, whatever I can do to help you,
I'm happy to do it.
I love to help entrepreneurs, for sure.
Thank you.
Thank you Greg.
Greg Getzinger!
And next time bring a fork!
I'm telling you. Thank you so much.
And Mark, timing is everything.
I have waited a very long time to meet you.
I was always so drawn to not just your light,
but your intention,
and you have been such a fearless leader,
you've helped extend yourself to teach others
how to find their dreams, and I find it so admirable-
Thanks.
That you don't believe in shortcuts,
you believe in treating people well along the way.
That in itself might be one of the most valuable lessons
that you give out, as well as many others.
Thank you so much.
Thanks, Drew.
I'm so happy to meet you.
And congratulations Greg.
Thank you.
Good job, good job.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much.
All right, Mark Cuban.
Shark Tank airs Friday, 8/7 Central on ABC.
And we'll be right back.
(bright theme music)